on a mission to deliver the very best
wine that we could dollar for dollar
of uh
at the price points that we sell it at
and so that started you know two years
ago with
uh wines at a 20 price point this is
basically just the manifestation of that
at a very very premium level
um and it's fun to actually talk to a
lot of the people that are probably
watching this just given that they're
you know deep into nft culture like i
would put
the vineyard sites that we source from
the farming the quality of wine making
very much in like the ultra ultra blue
chips of all wine making so
this is sourced from some of napa's most
prestigious vineyards for wine geeks
they would know
these vineyards very very well um and
what we set out to do is deliver a wine
that would otherwise cost
you know
in some cases 200 plus dollars a bottle
for
um a much much more fair
nate what are the three price points
uh 70 if you buy a per bottle if you buy
a case
uh 75 if you buy per bottle if you buy
six and then 85 per bottle if you buy
three and shipping's included in all of
those prices
um
i mean that's it that's it in a
in a snapshot i think the wine itself um
i think what's cool about it is it's
delicious right now so you could like
open this for the holidays and um enjoy
it with family it's also for those that
want to have a keepsake or a collectible
for a long time this is something that
if you store it properly you could age
for 20 or more years so
um let me jump in here because we've now
got all the garyvee channels live hi
everybody you are joining us for a very
special event uh john and nate uh are my
partners in empathy wines we sold the
company to consolation i went to
constellation these guys and the rest of
the team there and said hey what about a
collaboration with empathy elephant from
the friends uh and we produced a super
premium 2019 napa valley cabernet that
we are selling right now you can go to
garybee.com
empathylive um we're really excited
about this uh
we are almost sold out uh it is a wine
to john's point and we're going to get
into it i think i haven't tasted it yet
you two have it feels like you two have
i taste a couple times tiny bed
yeah so this is first for me
we set out
to produce a two
225 dollar quality wine which is what we
did
um
and as john was just saying
we have three versions of this being
sold right now you can buy a three pack
a six-pack a 12-pack with free shipping
just between black friday and cyber
monday we probably won't make it to
cyber monday as we're already almost
we're more than halfway sold out um
it's a collectible i will be signing
bottles at vcon
um
it's a one-time thing
uh and john will talk about the 2019
version but i see a ton of you
are in the comments and i need all of
you that are part of the vayner nation
and the v friends universe please link
in linkedin in all these different chats
the url to the site i'm going to tweet
it right now if you want to go to my
twitter
i'm going to do that john talk us
through 2019.
2019 um overall it's being considered
like a a really high quality vintage in
napa valley um i mean for anybody who's
paying attention to the news you know
that
the area has been subject to a lot of
wildfires thankfully in 2019
uh this portion of california was
entirely for the most part spared um
and so the wines coming out of there are
really really good i think all the you
know major wine critics are considering
it a top-notch vintage
um and it's like in general i would say
a a warmer vintage so
wines are pretty big ripe
um
rich like it's a it's a it's a big wine
um which i tend to like they know a lot
of people like that style so that's
definitely what you're getting here
nate thoughts
i would uh echo everything john said
we've tasted through
i think three or four different blends
with some small tweaks to what we really
wanted to make for this particular wine
and all three of us ended up with this
particular blend that you're tasting um
we were really blown away by it so
excited to get it as we keep building
the anticipation for this couple things
one join the discord
everybody who's in these chats right now
please share the discord link get
everybody into be friends discord here's
why
later today this black friday is not
just about empathy elephant 2019
cabernet from empty wines it is also
about me giving away a free
go token that's right
garyvee.com discord a free go token
for today between 3 and 7 p.m in the
discord i will be giving you the rules
you need to have a twitter
you need to change your twitter profile
picture right now
to
a v friend
uh and you'll see a bunch of those in
twitter and a bunch of those in discord
and people in discord can help you so
i'm giving away a go token i also just
previewed that i'm doing a contest for
people this week i'm gonna do it twice
because most people don't have their
books but a lot of people who are
getting the book games tokens bought 12
24
260 500 800
i'm doing a book giveaway so free for
everybody's watching getting free books
from be friends community members who
bought books for the tokens can be a
real thing on twitter so pay very close
attention to my twitter there's no
shipping outside the u.s but
if you use your friends in the discord
let's put up the discord link again
what's going on in the discord right now
is people from different countries are
finding friends in the discord to ship
the wine to and then those people are
shipping it to them or bringing it to
them at v-con
there's a lot going on today
multiple v-friends giving being given
away i mean the cheapest fee friends now
are like 50 000 so big day and
the official sale
of empathy elephant cabinet it's time to
give it a snippy sniff boys
uh one more time in this chord link
people are asking
garyvee.com discord
so i got linked up with gary because of
wine library tv
about 12 years ago where i
was a
college kid that was interested in wine
discovered gary through wine library tv
just looking up different wine
uh tutorials and education stuff and
thought like oh this guy's cool he's
talking wine in business
sent him a random email
out of the blue saying hey can i intern
from you i'll move to new jersey over
the summer
and um
i don't think i oh i heard back he said
yes
and i'm like
and i'm like i don't know what to do
with this but um his assistant followed
up with me because
uh he went to arizona state for graduate
school and i went to arizona state for
undergrad and he wanted to talk about
some bars in the area and so he kind of
set me up made it happen that was 13
years ago 12 years ago
um and have been working with gary in
different capacities ever since which is
just wild what a
random out of the blue email can can do
to your life it's still happening
like uh scott no we unfortunately
believe it or not in the most ironic
twist of fate empathy cannot ship to new
jersey so we can't ship it there so
you're gonna have to use your friends in
new york city uh john what about your
story of how we got connected
um mine's not too different from nate's
i uh i think mine just started on
twitter and then led to meeting you at
the boston wine expo in
2008. yeah i needed volunteers to give
out my cds i was giving out cds
of
wine library tv yep what's funny now is
like there are so many
am i the first person that did free work
for you that went on to work with you
for a long period of time
because like that's now like the
playbook right
yeah i mean your free work was not that
hardcore right was your internship
unpaid in corked unpaid six months
that was massive yeah well
it's people don't get it i mean i would
do it now like i probably work for jeff
bezos for six months for free i'd turn
it into roi positive i still i get why
people
you know people like oh that's only for
people that rich parents ironically i
find it to be in the extremes it's
either the wealthy or the like [ __ ] i
got nothing so [ __ ] i'm gonna use my
grind right um
you know obviously
we don't do that as much now it's all
kind of paid minimum internships but i
still feel like the free gangsters still
do a little bit like you know become
13-year relation i mean think about the
roi of that for you
i'd do it all over again
yeah well i mean
anyway yeah
um no i met you the boston wine expo hit
it off with your team same guy matt
sedimer who set me up originally and
um that then led to an internship at
corked which was early days of social
networks we were building a niche wine
social network
and really just basically cut my teeth
and let me let me jump in here real
quick by the way everybody who's
spamming in the content
in the comments about your nft projects
it is the most guaranteed way for me to
not be interested in the project
guaranteed free shipping on everything
by the way
um
free shipping on everything if you want
to talk to me get in my discord
garyvee.com discord if you want to talk
to me i see the comments the spam is
ridiculous we'll see we're gonna let's
start banning some people too it's just
like a complete waste of time
um
i'll see garage you're finished all
right let's uh let's get into this wine
snippy sniff time
yes i like that little scrolling thing
you did dust underneath nice nice job
um
so mine's only been open for about 45
minutes
big nose a lot of red fruit
but still tight for me i just didn't i
did i should have opened it earlier uh
for people that are asking how to order
garyvee.com empathy live we're going to
discord people are sharing the url
pretty aggressively in there
um what are you getting on the nose team
getting a little leather on the nose too
yeah like tobacco-y kind of like
cigar-ish like but then a lot of like
the red fruit that you said gare like
big shout out to 121. just ordered 12
i'm reading my discord as we're hanging
out here big shout out
yeah the fruit is amazing
i love this carlos underscore c ordering
more as people are starting to realize
it's almost gone and they are going to
flip it
i love the fact that people are going to
flip that's exactly right uh joe roubini
many people from canada are ordering
because they're getting friends in
discord in buffalo in washington state
in in other idaho
teaming up a lot of teaming up a lot of
vermont and new hampshire friends
helping out as well gary you're signing
bottles at uh v con i am okay i'm trying
to meet every single person at b-con
um
nate your
wedding
you decided was vikon's weekend that
really i i
we booked the wedding before the v con
date was announced and i didn't know it
yeah i should have told you that first
thing agent is the most important wall
because he wanted to go to all of i'm
stuck i'm like oh this is just i'm like
a super upset slash
i got [ __ ] but but i have like i have no
choice aj's in this spot aj's going to
the wedding obviously which is the
appropriate thing but he's going to try
to come to he's going to come for like a
day or two
is friday evening going to be your
rehearsal dinner rehearsal dinner but
yeah
yeah
such as life
you will be missed
i'm devastated that's the only bad thing
about beacon so far
all right let's get into this
wow
we're going to win this game big shout
out to zane
um oh jody has a great idea nate says
that you should switch your wedding to
minnesota
um i will definitely ask tessa's parents
about that but
uh the discord is garyvee.com discord
for everybody who's watching right now
that's in comments on facebook and
youtube and all these chats please share
the urls to the discord and to the wine
oh mark lee just got a case big shout
out
this one should breathe for i'm seeing
the comments the one should brief first
of all this one should based on my first
initial attack on the mid palette the
tannin structure and the finish
this wine will last for 25 plus years as
a matter of fact nate
you should probably buy a case and it
should be your and tessa's
like
anniversary wine and you should drink it
like one bottle over yeah i've already
bought some but i should buy it i think
this is a 25 to 35 years in the cellar
wine
incredibly
big this is incredibly big
this is
absolutely
the kind of cabernet that in a blind
tasting that's you know what i'm going
to do that i'm going to do a blind
tasting with some serious heavyweights
in q1 i'm going to start doing some more
tasting get out there with some
friends that are into serious wine and
i'm gonna bring a bottle of this
and uh
and i know that harlan and opus and
and
you know screaming eagle and scarecrow
and other monsters will be there and i
guarantee the empathy elephant is going
to have a massive showing massive
showing nate you want to rattle off the
states that you can't ship to just for
the people that are watching it's us
there are several states you know line
laws are tricky yeah currently alabama
arkansas delaware
um kentucky mississippi
ohio new jersey
and rhode island and utah
and remember all those states one more
time as nate rattles them off one more
time off the top and said you can find
your friends or have friends or work in
other states but the discord garyvee.com
discord is packed right now i'm going
into it while nate rattles off and i'm
gonna let john give his tasting notes
and i'm gonna go into the discord right
now and try to help some of you navigate
make sure the discord is very active in
helping people
okay alabama arkansas delaware kentucky
mississippi
ohio new jersey rhode island and utah
are currently where we cannot ship
um
alabama should change next year
ohio should change next year
um and we're working on working on new
jersey but that's that's out of our
hands there so
um yeah just the
the life of living in a wow crystal
group crystalgroves.ed
just helped out somebody that's in india
by letting them ship it to her in
pennsylvania that you can't believe
what's happening real teamwork kindness
in this discord right now
i love it uh john you want to give some
tasting notes while i'm in the discord
it's garyvee.com discord if you want to
join i'm in here just helping you want
to do a little something
yeah i uh i don't think i've had a sip
of this wine now for like two minutes
and i'm still tasting it because it's
the finish is insane
insane
it's uh and it's like a it's a big one
but it's like uh it's funny i talk about
wine a lot like people and i probably
got that from you on wine library tv but
it's like uh it's like a football player
who goes on like dancing with the stars
like it's got real moves meaning like
it's not just huge and burly and like
big and overpowering it's also got some
like
nuance to it and delicacy um but yeah
it's it's a it's a delicious wine
shout out to robbie turnik my best
friend growing up he just picked up some
uh please tweet out your receipts or
your confirmations i'm engaging there as
well um
man this is such a big wine jesus christ
i mean
i know the source i know what this wine
is
obviously because i've worked with you
guys i just
didn't know it was gonna be this big
yeah i agree i didn't i don't think i
anticip you know it's been a little
weird in that but with some of these
vintages so the stuff i've been tasting
is from some of the fire vintages i
don't think i realize how strong these
19s are
18 and 19 were both i think awesome
vintages
20. there's just like no wine to speak
of
nate john any thoughts why don't we talk
about empathy overall maybe some people
want to get on subscriptions for the
holidays of that because i'm pretty
excited about our next vintage
yeah cool
actually nobody buy empathy yet i know
that's going to [ __ ] you guys up i i
have a real big plan for us
that i want to talk through with you on
monday
um
that i think is going to work for this
community
all right no one by empathy like it
uh but talk to us about what's been
going on with empathy what this what the
standard structure is for empathy
yeah so year over year um we we make a
a red a white and a rose all blends from
northern california
all priced at 20 bucks a bottle
jeff wells got kicked out of the discord
jeff
it i'm like very close to yeah i see it
thank you
um corso and may and like i trust them
blindly clearly something's a foot a
wrong i'm gonna let corso reach out to
you hit them up on twitter but you're
gonna have to explain it they've been
coming to me with people that have been
emailing me about bands and they've
never been egregious so i'd like to
understand why um
big shout out to mrs lynch who just
bought a second case
you know what i love about my community
they're they're so savvy because they
crushed on be friends they've crushed on
other things i see a lot of people
buying an extra case now because they
know exactly what they're gonna buy for
70 sell them for a buck fifty i just i
love the flip life so much
angelo what's good i recognize you
all right keep going
yeah so all sustainably farmed um we
offer a membership which gets you every
year over here the rose white and red of
the new vintage
and each year we're trying to source the
best grapes and blends that we can make
to just get that quality for the price
that we're trying to deliver
um really trying to highlight the
farmers in the areas that we're sourcing
our grapes from
um
and it's been you know this will be our
our fourth vintage upcoming
uh which is crazy uh we've continued to
have like such amazing feedback across
the the three core wines
and and next year we're going to think
about
you know what what else other than the
the friends empathy elephant we can add
to the portfolio to continue to
to have our customers try try new wines
and get that quality across different
types of products as well
big shout out to mark
mark zach roth just picked up a case i
just want to say thank you dad's corner
rips just got three bottles thank you so
much
really really really appreciate it
uh the product is not in total wines the
product's not even at wine library this
is only direct uh at the url garyvee.com
empathy live
um
mitch jackson you'd better give it a try
this is insane napa cab from 2019
wildly underpriced this is like the wine
version of the mint day of v friends
what you're getting inside versus what's
being charged at three six and twelve
bottles is
a joke
um to be frank
um
and uh puppy planet please stop spamming
youtube if you want to talk to me go
into the discord i'll really try i'm
trying my best um
uh jim shafer thank you for picking up
six three and three
um
so
yz guy
don't say damn i only bought three
three's amazing we love having you in
the community um
dustin
can you please come on board i'm gonna
do some surprises are you working with
corso
ice cream in may we will now take some
questions from people on my discord
correct
all right so discord god it's windy out
here discord uh i'm gonna go into the
discord right now
john nate can you recap everything for
people that are joining lee while i go
into discord and start telling them how
they can be on this live stream asking a
question
recap time men give it to everybody
who's just joining
all right i'll kick us off nate uh so a
couple days ago we announced a
collaboration with the v friends
team and empathy wines where we're
releasing the empty elf and 2019
cabernet sauvignon
some very limited edition wine we didn't
make a whole lot of it
it is a very very premium cabernet from
napa valley
um and really it's its mission is uh the
same as every other wine that we've made
with empathy wines it's to deliver the
very best wine for the price point that
we can
in this case the one that would
typically retail for you know north of
200 a bottle
um delivered to your door for for a
you know a
fraction of that price
and we sourced it from some of the best
vineyards did some negotiating um
with uh
with the different growers that we that
we sourced the grapes from and
um super super excited to taste it with
you all today
nate what i missed
um i think that's covers it i mean i
think we said it's a wine you could
probably drink
now but something that'll age for 25 to
30 years be like really awesome
collectible you know gary it's the first
real like cpg collaboration that you've
done with the of the friends character
if i'm not mistaken
uh yeah this is a preview right like you
know and oh let's also talk about for
people that might have just stumbled
into this if you own the befriend token
from series one of last glass standing
or sensible sommelier
you get three free bottles of this wine
three free bottles so just go to
befriends.com and you'll check click in
connect your wallet you'll see it at the
top and if you own an empathy elephant
you get six free bottles of this which
is pretty rad and i'll be doing a lot of
that stuff i want to make sunflower
seeds i want to make socks i want to
make beanies and i'm going to be doing
collaborations with characters to your
point wine is collectible and auction
offable and winebid.com a bowl and all
that kind of stuff and it's the first
one i did do a street wear collaboration
with patient you know prospective pigeon
and jake staple so it's a little
apparel but yes this is the first
consumable package cpg and we got a ton
more massive amounts of announcements
here in december and january but this is
the first in product form and obviously
it's empathy wines which i was a
co-founder of like this really excites
me
in a lot of ways uh in a lot of ways
i also need to know i'm sorry
if anybody was trying to shift to
louisiana we just made a quick update
there was issues before there shouldn't
be issues now louisiana is now fixed
let me just put that into the discord
all right um
from corso if you could just text me
and tell me that you and dustin are
kind of we good i'm just texting you
guys in may right now
um we don't need somebody right now but
i'll tell you when i want somebody so if
you can have one or two or three people
in um
in the queue
um the discord is lit anyone here from
chicago looking for a lot of stuff going
on in the comments here i'm really
excited the wine is spectacular
recapping it one more time i mean if
this was old wine library tea let me get
an old wine library tv oh
all right well even though i said i
don't want somebody on we've got
somebody on and we're going to talk to
him smack what's good
yo what's going on how you guys doing
good man how are you i'm good good good
what's going on what can we answer for
you how you doing happy thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving
spent my day i finished the book
yesterday oh let's talk about that let's
talk about the book how fantastic yeah
tell me tell me what surprised you what
what got reaffirmed what is something
new that maybe even my content didn't
get you there and the book did
um i think the
well first my one of my favorite parts
about the book is the simplicity behind
it
um as a reader one of the things i love
is it's like when authors are concise
and i think gary your your style came
through and
shout out to raghav for the help just
like really punchy in terms of like what
you're trying to say versus like the
fluffiness behind it
um some of the things that maybe uh were
reaffirmed for me
just the importance of like kindness
like that word came up over and over and
over and over again like we were told
that kindness is not a core to business
maybe in life but when we talk about
business nobody talks about kindness and
i genuinely believe
that my empire is being built on it and
so many others are as well and so many
have and we've been lied to that you
have to be a dick face to win in
business
i've been i've definitely been in
situations
in work where you have to remind people
results and kindness are not mutually
exclusive correct
so that was a reaffirmation what else
um
the
one of the things that was noticeable in
every chapter
is this idea of balance
like it's like a dichotomy of like you
have to be this but you also have to
balance it with this
right and that's again connections which
is why i called it ingredients because
if you're gonna make a meal
it's like sweet and sour chicken right
they may seem like patience and ambition
confuse people i carry both of them
easily and that's where i was trying to
go with it yeah that now that was
perfect it was clear because it was a
good reminder for everyone that you have
you have to balance that
did you do any of the exercises yet
um i started doing the push-ups
yesterday
no [ __ ] yeah yep
i'm very passionate about it i think
most people will be scared to be
vulnerable to do the exercises because
i'm really pushing people in the
exercises to be like put your [ __ ] out
there kind of like a step i took with
kind candor which would blow people's
mind for people that follow garyvee but
for nate and john they're very aware
that i tried to manage in a way that any
way not to scare people but that led
people to being scared because i wasn't
candorous enough as a matter of fact
when they were in the office of the co i
would say that was the prime era where i
probably needed a lot more candor when
we would three of us along with mattabel
and marcus the five of us we would talk
about the shortcomings of individuals a
lot and try to navigate their exit or
how to help them
where if i just had a sit down and was
cancerous half of them would have been
salvaged but i didn't have that ability
at that point in my career
yeah i think uh peop anybody that
looks back and goes damn i didn't do any
of the challenges or like exactly the
people in the book that you were talking
to
about like being correct yeah and a lot
of people are gonna pick the being
vulnerable people can pick the push-ups
one because it's like easier the one
where you like make a video and post on
social media and talk about what you
suck at it's just like a hard thing to
ask people to do
did you did you just say i just did the
easy one gary i did i did smac
smack do you only do you own any bee
friends yeah um three um two for myself
one for my wife um we got two it we got
two at mint
um i got a stoic slime yes um i
convinced my my wife to get one she was
dead against um nfts yeah she thought
the whole thing was
stupid totally and i was like listen if
there's one thing you never do you never
get bad against vic gary and she was
like who i'm just kidding she knows who
you she knows who you are um
who met against me by taking quick
profits off the table
can you please tell these guys who knew
me for 15 [ __ ] years what's the
matter with them i would say i didn't
bet it against you
ever
i i moved to new york because of you i
stayed in new york you're like 10 years
old
john nate is this i actually don't know
so you're telling me both of you do not
own a b friend right now that's correct
i don't
i sold my spiffy salmon i but my bet
wasn't i was short-sighted on nfts i
thought that there was going to be a
spike in the market and then i'd be able
to flip it and get back in
learn the lesson the hard way floor shot
up
hold on one second the one thing i can
guarantee now is that i'm not joining
meta billionaire because of all the spam
that's in my youtube so let's uh
um
corso may anybody who's watching can we
please bam all these people that are
pumping their
their nft projects i just want to ban
all of them block all of them it's
completely ridiculous it's it's super
sad
i actually was looking at that project
as something i was interested in now i'm
definitely not doing it because of the
spam um and so that's that anyway smack
thank you so much brother i'll see you
at v-con yep i'll be there give me the
other two what's that
stoic slime oh
uh warm wolverine
i got something big broom with warm
water nice and then um the one i picked
up after market i got an epic humble
hummingbird
my man
thank you guys can you believe how crazy
they are compared to how much they were
at mint
oh it's insane i mean it kind of
expected i mean what does your wife say
now
um
she will never ever ever sell it she was
like
this this is it i'm keeping it so she's
uh she totally gets it she spent a lot
of time with me diving into nfts and
stuff spend a lot of time with me and
discord so a huge fan of it all love it
thank you so much let's keep moving um
uh
all right let's um
let's uh
let's get another person here this is
pretty fun
racks what's good
yo what's up gary what's up everyone
how's it going
two things that i observed besides the
obvious that you're anonymous is that
you are both have an empathy book behind
you oh and also an adorable child and
you have a t-shirt of the ones that i
get oh
there he is
by the way you just showed your face
let's get this yeah
no worries no worries you got the shirt
that means you were in line at the uh at
the secret wine party i appreciate you
got a bottle of empathy wines too or no
is that a what oh yeah
we got some after wine party
my wife had to get one and she wanted to
try it so i had to fire one how are you
i'm doing great i had a great
thanksgiving yesterday had some good
family time nothing crazy yeah chill
good family time that's the best stuff
how about yourself really good anything
i can answer for you while we're
together
yeah so i'm not a wine collector
i
just bought 12 of the
empathy wine
collab
and
how do you store them what should i do
to
keep them
so if you have a garage or a basement
they'll probably be consistent and cool
enough
given that these have a dark horse
chance not guaranteed i'm not promising
this
but i do plan on dominating the earth
and i do think that how little there is
of this and how cruel it is
there is a dark horse chance that these
could become
500 1 000 collectibles in the future
that may in a world where you paid 70
bucks for it it might be worth it for
you to buy like a 300 small john name
maybe you can help me here i don't know
how much a 24 or 36 or 48 bottle wine
fridge cost these days the racks
given the appreciation value it's not
the worst idea
to maybe buy a tiny wine fridge plug it
in somewhere and just put the bottles
there john nate thoughts on that
yeah i think it's the move if you're
definitely looking to hold these for you
know a decade or more like you can get
really solid wine fridges at like a
costco or bj's or one of those big uh
big box stores for a couple hundred
bucks
um and it'll it'll make sure the wine
safe and sound and
keeps uh keeps for a long time
cool appreciate it yeah thank you guys
rax thank you so much for being artist
community do you have some beef friends
i do
i have a couple
minted all of them yeah you don't need
to you don't need to go further i love
you my man have a great holiday
appreciate you guys see you guys have a
good one
everybody's asking where the discord is
that's where all the action is go to
garyvee.com
discord um
highly recommend you become part of our
discord community especially because for
the people who are still watching
there's a very big thing going on which
is tonight this evening this afternoon i
am giving away a freebie friend shortly
actually i might even do it soon a
freebie friend look for that offering um
that is happening today
free v friend coming shortly uh on my
discord and a
more details on the book giveaway a lot
of you have 144 books 244 books all
sorts of numbers 2412 asking for ways to
do clever things with this i think
there's a lot more people that actually
want the book in hand so my plan is to
do two giveaways one this upcoming week
one
in between christmas and new year's
where
you document how you're doing the
giveaway on twitter get people to get
the book from you
and then i
uh randomly select two people and give
an epic go which is very expensive
uh so look for more of that info so
please go to garyvee.com discord and get
into
uh the discord now that's where the
action is big shout out to mark who is
ordering one in the next 10 minutes
leave a comment right now on facebook
twitter linkedin who's ordering some
empathy elephant cabernet please give me
a signal right now if you are and if
you're interested in buying that go to
garyvee.com empathy live i'm gonna share
that link right now um who is ordering
right now and let's get somebody else in
here as we speak
hi
hi chrisley
i'm sorry i'm a little bit overwhelmed
so i'm really glad to be here
how are you where are you from
i'm from the netherlands actually but my
parents are from ukraine uh and i joined
the discord like a week ago i've been
active every day doing my research and
really enjoying the community
well we love having you part of uh
the community uh john nate say hello
please
hey chris how are you
yeah i'm really good how are you
good cody stevens thank you for your
three ernesto thank you for your three
shining thank you for your 20. it does
not ship to canada peter but if you go
into the discord and you live in another
country or in a state that you can't
ship to in the discord right now
garyvee.com discord many people are
teaming up having the wine shipped to
them and helping lots of friendships
chrisley is there anything i can answer
for you
actually uh no i've just really been
observing everything you say so soaking
it all up so i don't feel the need to
ask questions because i have so much
content to listen to to watch too so
after i did all that i will sure have
some questions
i loved it i love it i love it well
listen thank you for being part of the
community and
uh for for people like chrisley and
others who are just getting in series 2b
friends comes out in q1 by the way i
love your outfit is that
is that the disney character what's his
name yeah it's it's stitch and it's like
woody so it's until my knees
melissa for everybody like grizzly as
you might have known in the discord in
there series two is coming out in q1 i'm
committed that the v friends in series
two are less than a thousand dollars usd
um whatever if you're in ethereum
whatever the price is then so look for
that as well chrisley thank you so much
for being part of it thank you for
inviting me of course
what should we talk about because i'm
getting updates that we're getting
i think we're gonna have enough
like there's still some
um some
it's getting close it's getting close
what uh what should people know about
the wines
john just had a swig um i mean i just
keep going back to it as we're talking
which i think is always the sign of a
really good wine is something that you
just kind of drink without even thinking
about and it's delicious so
um i don't this was a this was like a
very new thing for us we've always been
around the 20 per bottle honestly i
didn't know how this was going to
perform with our community in the
defense community doing something so
premium but the wine is so
damn good um that i think that we we
really delivered on on the price point
that we're selling it so by the way a
couple things that just popped up yes
uh
you will get these wines asap
so the wine is available and when i say
asap i know it's gonna be a little delay
here nate but you do feel confident-ish
i know logistics and some things are out
of your control but we will be getting
these out in early early december so
most people that have ordered it will
have it in time for their christmas
table correct or christmas gifts
yes it will be there before christmas
i love it
i love it ending any carrier issues and
all that stuff it's crazy out there
right now with with carriers and
shipping but
we will we will have it out as soon as
possible for for before christmas
john nate can you guys hold the
floor for two minutes while i go into
the discord and talk to everybody and
maybe give everybody a recap and
thoughts and anything else what we're
doing here
yeah sure
go ahead yeah i think uh
no i think just building on what nate
was saying around like parting thoughts
as we get close to wrapping up from my
standpoint um it's not lost on me that
85 for a bottle of wine is is a lot of
money even though i think it's like a
tremendous value at the price point
um i think for people who are interested
in wine like
kind of a budding interest in it like we
make a lot of other wines at a 20 price
point it's a ton more approachable and
affordable
um if you guys have any questions or
anything about like
getting wine education or anything like
that hit me up on twitter trouty like
would love to um help advise people on
like their early shopping early buying
even like outside empathy wines just
like advice on getting into wine i think
it's a lot like nfts where like you
start to go down a rabbit hole and learn
a little bit and you get more and more
excited and you just realize it's like
an endless journey so
um yeah that would be that'd be kind of
my thought is like hit me up i'd love to
help anybody um
help them like coach them through their
their early wine buying days
i love that
um a lot i'm seeing a lot of questions
to discord canada we can't ship new
jersey we can't ship there are several
places we cannot ship however
if you go into discord i'm watching it
happen right now in front of my face
people are helping each other
um helping each other get the wine there
are tons of people in new york and
pennsylvania buying for people in new
jersey as we speak
there's a ton of people in new hampshire
wyoming
idaho
and washington state that are helping
people in canada depending on what part
they are i've also seen people from
india and the philippines getting helped
as well the uk as well so if you go in
there and say can anybody help me
uh people are doing that ivan b thank
you for just picking up your six bottles
just right now
uh the reason not jersey is state laws
are different and jersey's state laws
for wineries is different than retailers
and there's a lot of things
um
that you know jersey has some
intricacies for sure
uh
we previously were able to and now we're
not but we're working on that
yep
um
cool
uh let's get somebody else on here
because i know there's somebody in the
back and this wine is stupid
spencer what's good
hey what's going on gary how are you
doing things are well how are you
excellent pleasure to be interacting
with i'm a uh like sitting in the wine
library today one of my every day is a
lurker been around for a while and uh
just you know really getting involved
never had any
crypto or nfts or anything like that
um and when you started talking about
the project i was like man let me just
jump in and i've told friends it wasn't
even really so much is
buying cryptocurrency or buying nft i
saw it as a way to buy stock and gary
vaynerchuk um from
all that you've been i'm not even a wine
drinker um you know just
you know watching you on you know
youtube when you're first starting out
and your passion and interest
in
in the content
is what got me starting to follow you
years ago and um so yeah so
ended up getting in got a dedicated
dragonfly and that's on instagram my
name is uh dragonfly fern bass i'm a
bass player and so that's why
that's why i ended up getting a uh a
dragonfly one and
you know so much of what you talk and
cut tell me to stop if i'm talking too
much but
um you uh what you talked about is so
encouraging and have gone through a lot
of uh difficult times in life lately
with a dragonfly they live the majority
of their life underwater but then when
they come out they have the highest
success rate of uh hunting in the animal
kingdom and so that's why i ended up
i was like this is like the
part two of my life journey i really
feel and that was why i ended up going
with the uh dedicated dragonfly so
what's amazing about that is
and you bought a core at the floor yeah
it's a core one um
did you buy a floor at 0.5 yes sir yes
sir it was 0.5
how do you like i mean that's just
such a come up in such a short period of
time like yeah
let me tell you this though here here's
my and
no doubt about it totally grateful don't
i don't want anyone to twist this and
what i'm about to say
i feel like i'm holding a mickey mantle
working card that i can never sell like
going up in value but i know
it's why it's why my brother aj buys two
of everything because then you get stuck
if you had two you would have sold one
now for a 60 000 come up and you would
have been like [ __ ] right yeah that's it
no i would have been paying for i'm i'm
going to be at vcon i'm trying to get my
brother to go with me he doesn't have a
deep friend i'm trying to get him to go
just to be i want him to he's an artist
i want him to be in the space in the
environment just moving around even
though he can't get in i'm like you know
we'll meet up with people for dinner and
stuff like that and i don't you know
corso
first of all shout out to my man corso
who let me in uh in the thing um he's
been great during the nfl chat that was
how i got connected with him so thank
you corso for letting me hop in here but
yeah but we just want him to be able to
meet the people and um you know and be
around and be in that environment to get
him involved in the ft space with uh the
work that he does artistically so i'm
just you know
excited about the
opportunity for one second people are
asking if i gave the go away yet not yet
uh that will be coming up shortly that
will be happening in the discord
looking at the numbers on on the wine
were well over 50 percent of the way
there were probably 70 percent 80 of the
way there
there may be you know this will probably
trickle after this because we'll be off
here soon
will be one more email that we send on
monday morning on cyber monday because
this is from right now until cyber
monday i don't think it's going to last
as people start to
chat but i just want to give everybody a
clarity transparent update
spencer i think you're right on the
brother thing i think you should push
them because the nut you know we're
ending
the content somewhere around eight
o'clock each night and i think from 8 30
to 2 in the morning there's gonna be
action in hotel rooms restaurants that
that minis minneapolis
during that three four days is going to
be out of control with like good vibes
and people in the discord meeting up and
i think you should push him and i'm so
glad you have
that and if you don't even know
bro i got the nft i got um
i picked up three bottles earlier this
morning
um you know so listen the book the book
nft book games obviously that's coming
real short i'll be next i think people
are going to be really surprised and you
know i haven't really been obvious about
this yet but i'll share it with you like
even if you bought 12 where you get one
token you could get the token so it's
gonna be really fun
it's gonna be really exciting and book
games is forever i'm gonna be doing
things with the book tokens forever
um i'm going to lay it all out there's a
lot to do right away
and to play
and then there'll be something around
vcon and really forever so i'm really i
think it's going to be a good token and
tokens to own cool
good stuff all right brother we'll talk
soon
i got the green on for you you know
bailey avenue in the bronx got you know
you got my jet stream but thank you
for having me in the bronx so my
grandfather used to play handball down
there so i love that it's no pleasure my
man stay well all right yeah all right
cheers
wrapping up here guys
uh we'll get one more person in i'll
call that person in a few minutes let's
just recap please go to garyvee.comd
live especially now as we're getting
down that stretch if you want to get
your wine this is absolutely the time um
to get in
um
you can still buy books but not for the
nfts um
um
and
let's just actually take let's just
taste the wine one more time to give
people a preview
the red fruit is so like the raspberry
strawberry like kind of jam thing oh big
shout out to tk's
taksu kim two cases this is definitely
the stretch
you know i love that little photo he has
uh or she has um couldn't see but uh at
um fenway park
the uh
the thing about it is like i've already
gone through a quarter of a bottle of
wine like it's just easy to drink it's
just delicious so i'm gonna be ready for
it now
crazy how easy it is to drink and how
big it is um i think it's like the
very interesting cool thing about it
yeah it's it's actually just like i
think it falls into that cult wine like
to me this reminds me of the harlans and
the screaming eagles and the scarecrows
and the
you know just the super two three four
hundred dollar wines in napa that i've
drank over the last 25 years that's
that's why i think i i gotta go look
back at the way i reacted when i first
tasted it i'm curious how my eyes
shifted because i was like oh okay this
is not a [ __ ] joke i i would say if
people are gonna open one of these soon
to definitely let it let it open and air
out for at least yeah why didn't just
ask howard attendance they're big but
they're sweet
the tannins are delicious which is why
they're palpable right now
but um
um
brianna if you're just joining right now
if you buy three bottles you get three
bottles there's no attachments just a
there's three six and twelve bottle
orders available uh if you go to
garyvee.com empathy live um
there's nothing that happens we've just
got a very super premium i i think when
i taste this is a 235 napa cab and
that's that's my peg price in my mind
quality wise what i feel comfortable
paying for it um and so we've got this
have what 80 remind me guys if you buy
yeah this is a three four hour breather
to be honest really it's a four to five
hour decanter and really it's a six to
12 years in the seller like it's massive
uh recap the pricing team
yeah so we sell in three six and 12
packs shipping is included on every
order um at three bottles it's 85 a
bottle um so i think that's two 255.
um free shipping on all by the way
everyone's good on everything and then
six bottles is priced at 75 a bottle uh
and 12 bottles is priced at 70 a bottle
by the way see multiple people just now
from jersey being upset i mean like new
york city and pennsylvania like philly
and new york city or allentown pa if
you're out in west jersey like new
jersey is the easiest state to ship to
somewhere else like i don't want to hear
that like that should be super easy get
into the discord people are absolutely
helping each other get their wine
let's do that um let's get the last
person in here before we get out of here
rodrigo
sounds weird
it's on your end
i like how rob
rodriguez you know like i do normally
victor's hair no no shirt he's just
coming at it rodrigo something's going
on it sounds like
like the sound's off okay i'll let you
guys play
um people asking globally unfortunately
we can't ship globally it's u.s only
predominant states um most states but
some can't um but if you go into the
discord discord.com befriends or
garyvee.com discord
nikos don't say [ __ ] you'll be fine go
into the discord there are people
helping each other out so much right now
so much
i'm going into the discord
um
wow
we're
uh crazy how fast this is selling here
there's not a not a whole line left
is it true
yeah
well i'm just doing something discord
let's try rodrigo one more time if not
we're gonna jump out
he's reloading the page
we'll give him two more minutes
i gotta go back to family cards where we
go
okay is it better now
it's better now my friend welcome
hey guys hey guys thank you
how are you
i'm great i'm great it's hot in here
that's why i'm fearless
good
yeah
it's very good
uh
well
i just i just want to thank you because
you know like uh i first got in contact
in contact with your uh content like a
year ago my brother actually
showed you to me
and uh
i'm i've been really
really into your content and how you
talk about kindness and gratefulness and
everything like it actually has changed
my the way i think you know the way i
see life so i'm a better person right
now i think
and so i just want to thank you for this
thank you my friend where do you live
i live i live in in brazil in rio
very nice beautiful city
yeah yeah really beautiful city well
thank you you don't know how much that
means to me and thank you so much for
being part of the discord community you
enjoying it
yeah yeah for sure
lots of nice friends
yeah yeah i have uh i own a different
one
no
yes yes
thank you i'm so proud of you
yeah man it's crazy did you buy it did
you buy it at mint yeah yeah
wow
which one do you have really
the grateful uh grit for gorilla
wow really
yes yes gratitude gorilla gratitude yeah
sorry yes granite
court yeah the car one rodrigo never
sell that i think the gorilla the
orangutan
because of what's going on with um
with board ape and with crypto punks
where the ape is very expensive all of
the apes
and gorillas and orangutans and monkey
all that stuff inside of the friends is
very underpriced right now from a
collectible standpoint and i actually
think gratitude gorilla is at the top so
i think you [ __ ] man you really nailed
it
thank you thank you uh i really
appreciate what you've been doing for
the community
i'm happy to do it
yes happy to do it i love you pal have a
great great holiday well i'll see are
you going to be able to make
rodrigo are you going to be able to make
it to v con or is it too tough
i'm not sure
i work so it depends on work
but i'm looking forward to it
cheers
we'll talk soon see ya well listen
everybody thank you for being with us
for this last hour it was uh incredibly
enjoyable always fun to be with you john
and nate
um
let's uh i'm gonna answer a couple
questions i see in here uh book tokens
will be sellable on secondary of course
anything that's an nft will be
um
i'm super excited and very thankful for
all of you uh here's the hint on the
go giveaway i'm to be doing it shortly
um and it will be super fun
and
please be in the discord
so discord.com garyvee or garyvee.com
discord excuse me um is the right url uh
should be a big deal should be a big
opportunity
um
and
i'm just really excited for all of you
to be a part of this journey one last
final push for the wine
empathy elephant from empathy wines 2019
cabernet
um
we are down the home stretch on the wine
so
please go to the discord if you're
struggling to get the wine to your place
um really really excited about it um
and
just very excited about this community
this journey the book tokens are coming
in late lately december book games are
starting there's going to be some
giveaways if you give away your actual
physical books look for that in discord
follow me on twitter and discord that's
where everything is happening uh and i
hope everybody has a wonderful rest of
their thanksgiving weekend in the us or
other parts of the world just a good
week um john nate love you guys thank
you
in the ballpark of 70 to 80
which means
we'll probably i'm gonna ask the guys to
send another email in a couple hours to
the rsvp list to make sure they all saw
it we'll do another one probably on
friday saturday excuse me saturday
sunday and monday
and
um
and that'll be it so this should be
pretty gone pretty soon this could
normally after things like this too
there's a big push as soon as i actually
hang up so
that could even sell it out there's just
not a lot of wine left so
thank you anything you guys want to park
shops with
no just appreciate everyone uh listening
in and
picking up some wine a crazy amount of
wine sold today only a few bottles left
so really appreciate all the support
from this community i'm excited for you
to try the wine yeah
just uh yeah nate said it best thank you
to everybody um
really appreciate all this i apologize i
apologize john mr axis that's a great
question pairings um
you know this is big stick wine this is
big cheese wine this is big um this is
big uh
uh
um
cigar life our wine maker said roasted
lamb shank grilled ribeye braised short
ribs things like that would be awesome
pairings for this wine
john sorry
no i'm uh i
pretty much summed it up well maybe
parting thought is i have to go buy my
spiffy salmon back
yeah i don't know um i don't know what
you were thinking why don't you actually
give us well i actually want to hear
both of your stories what did you mint
and what did you sell
it for
so go ahead john
so i bought mine right after mint for i
think like point seven and then i
flipped it like
four and a half
something like that was how much did you
make in profit
uh it was like in a short window like it
it scott like eath was right around the
same value when i sold like not but east
hadn't appreciated that much
so did you make like six like 16 000 or
like 10 000 or like what was it
yeah whatever the delta was between
what you don't know or what are you
being shy like we need to help people
here no no well i made like three and
three and a half eighth on it
do you still have the eighth
yeah
so your you bet on eath more than you
bet on me is basically what i'm sensing
well every i've re-deployed it but i'm
about to come back into the friends now
series two
that's right how many are you gonna get
oh nice
they're gonna be about 950 bucks a piece
if i can time it with the eighth price
obviously there might be a 24 hour thing
and look what happened it was 4 500 and
4 000 but what do you think
what do you think um
how many be friend series two do you
think you buy what's your gut
five
there i love that number
nate your story would you buy what you
sell i never got one because my meta
mask was [ __ ] up
and i tried to get the stoic slime
multiple times so did i give you one i
don't remember no
okay um so what happened so you didn't
own one ever
and then it skyrocketed quickly and i'm
like [ __ ] should i get it now i'm like
no i'll wait for it to come down it
never came down
but i'm gonna go heavy in the series two
how many do you think you'll buy
at least 10.
you're twice the friend that john is
nate i love you five times two parting
thought also parting thought
sun's over next tonight oh yeah we
didn't even talk about our big battle
tonight you guys are super hot though
right yeah 14 in a row i'm sure i'll be
there for the for the first loss right
you're going tonight yeah
it sucks because i love taking you to
that game that's kind of our thing but
it was this holiday weekend so
anyway love you guys love you g talk
soon everyone cheers everyone thank you
for watching everybody please everyone
share the link to empathy wines um
what's that someone said sun stink tough
i'm not wrong
um
and for everybody who has bottles of
decon i will sign as many as i can
and yes at vcom we will have flea market
like dynamics where people can sell this
a lot of cool stuff a lot of things to
think about we'll talk soon make your
last last-ditch efforts please enjoy for
the holidays bye everyone everyone
thanks everyone